so an article was posted i'm with chris
hogan i talked about it on monday at
cnn.com cuz CNN money CNN own money
magazine and money.com and it went broke
of course and closed up which is kind of
ironic when you think about money
but uh but that's a side issue there
were a piece of trash anyway so that's
okay
but the not like i have strong feelings
about them is your opinion what do you
think well i mean put a cartoon of me on
your cover and trash me and i'll always
love you for life you know so anyway the
CNN does an article monday this says
since they don't have the money thing
that they have to still do money that
says that people are saving money at the
best rates since ronald reagan and how
again and i are like yes and what this
proves is that even in hard times you
can save money if saving money is a
priority it is not a oh i their systemic
problems with the economy and the rich
are getting richer and the poor are
getting poorer and no one can save money
listen if your kids sick you can save
money save the kid you find the money to
save when it becomes important enough to
save money and how can i talk through
that so they've now expanded the article
to this ridiculous tripe americans are
slashing their spending hoarding cash
and shrinking their credit card debt as
they fear for their jobs could disappear
during the corona virus pandemic us
credit card debt suddenly reverse course
in march yes and fell by the largest
percentage in more than thirty years yes
at the same time savings rates climbed
to levels unseen since ronald reagan was
in the white house although caution is a
logical response to that uncertainty
hunkering down also poses a risk to the
economy to route to the recovery of an
economy dominated by consumer spending
the so called v-shaped recovery can't
happen if consumers are sitting on the
sidelines well let me help you guys with
this because apparently you haven't left
your newsroom lately you do not have a
v-shaped return to the economy when
entire states are still at home dumb but
I mean seriously
now that analysis could apply 30 to 90
days from now if the nation is back to
work right and there's still hoarding
cash and reducing debt you could make
that analysis but right now they're not
out spending anyway you doofuses unless
they're buying it on Amazon well in
California has what the largest GDP of
like five like the fifth largest in the
world right the only state of California
completely sure when they're so and
they're still shut down until the Falls
but they're saying with schools and
universities so yeah so all that to say
it's yeah it's not a correct analysis
when you look at it from well and here's
the thing and and then let's let's go
ahead and fast-forward and try to apply
the logic in a logical way rather than
the illogical way let's say that
Americans forever decide because they've
been through this that we are going to
be wiser and we're going to carry little
to no credit card debt and we're always
going to save money does that in fact
crash the economy in truth it does not
because here's the thing if households
are stabilized through their own
problems and through outside problems
they continue spending savings
stabilizes households if households
don't have as much credit card debt you
know what they have more money you know
what they do with some of that more
money they spend it so this is the same
dumb but logic that people have said
well if everyone in America followed
Dave Ramsey and didn't borrow money and
save money American economy would
collapse no it wouldn't collapse it
would boom because human beings would
actually have more money because they're
not giving it to banks and car companies
human beings would have more stability
in their lives because they would have
savings and it would cause a boom if you
used biblical principles for handling
money which is saving money and staying
away from debt and so it's the same
stupid idea that the consumer has a you
know you have a patriotic
obligation to spend your stimulus check
to stimulate the economy or scrap that's
I was gonna say that's like the
number-one argument right now or
question or suggestion of when you get
your simulus check and I was actually on
an interview and kind of got a little
bit combative put the anchor because
they're like no Rachel like because I'll
send them payout you know your four
walls use that simular your food your
dadgum frame or your house yes and and
to build up that strong financial
foundation for your family and then you
have the confidence to go out as
consumer to go and spend travel again
whatever it is where your money's before
your money's going oh yeah and he almost
like oh he was dying he was like Richard
you're making my head spin right now I
can't do it no no you want me to go out
and spin they need it they need to help
gin you know stimulate the economy with
this this is what it's being given to
them and I'm like no we're freaked out
with this and so use it for your own
household so you're exactly right that
when you have confidence in your own
home then that's when you're gonna go
out and actually spend the money that
you've earned
you're gonna go and even though you say
it's for it you're gonna go buy a
brand-new car you're gonna go out to
dinner you're in low do these things
with the money that you have because you
actually have the money and it goes with
the reason that the stimulus passed so
easily was several-fold obviously people
the politicians were trying to buy votes
obviously people were very scared and
they were trying to calm them down but
the other reason that the stimulus
passed so fast
and so easily is the same reason that
hanker believes that is that we have
been taught in school our whole lives
that Keynesian economics John Maynard
Keynes invented Keynesian economics
actually works which there's all kinds
of data that says it doesn't work
Keynesian economics is the government
creates jobs and stimulates the economy
it's what FDR did in the New Deal he
John Maynard Keynes convinced FDR
Franklin Delano Roosevelt to get us out
of the Great Depression by doing
government make work and so they created
the TVA they created all these PAGASA
tikkun ditches and cutting trees and
they created all these jobs that the
government was paying people that didn't
have jobs to work and that's supposedly
stimulated the economy out of the Great
Depression however there's a very valid
argument that no one talks about anymore
that World War two actually got us out
of the Great Depression
not John Maynard Keynes Keynesian
economics
so this idea that government should
interfere in the economy and stimulate
things is so widely believed because
it's taught as fact this idea of
Keynesian economics and people don't
know that's what it's called probably
unless they're econ student like me but
the you know but but this I and
basically John mentor Keynes was
socialist the idea that government is in
control of our lives in government
should be the nanny state and government
should take care of us and all of that
and we argued about this a lot back in
the 2008 crash the government has to get
involved because the German motorist is
too big to fail we have to bail them out
don't go when sax is failing or dead and
so but but hovering just below the
surface is this idea that in seventh
grade economics class it was a team that
Keynesian economics is fact that the
government's job one of their roles is
to jump in and bail the economy out and
stimulate the economy by creating cash
flow or jobs and it's absolutely false
there's nothing proven by it but oh here
we did it again at a record level at two
trillion freaking dollars Sam lots of
problems out there people you have to
think for yourself this is the Dave
Ramsey show